good afternoon everyone
thank you for being here
as my husband stated
this is the beginning of the process
we're going to be here at every court
day
so that they can know that we're here
they need to
I don't know I feel it's funny because I
feel very numb right now I feel very
numb and I'm waiting for
this nightmare basically that I'm going
through right now I'm waiting for
somebody to wake me up right I'm really
waiting for somebody to wake me up but I
also know that's not going to happen
okay I know my son is gone
I know I'll never see him again
but we have to start this process of
Justice right now and I want each and
every one of those police officers
to be able to look me in the face that
they haven't done that yet they couldn't
even do that today they didn't even have
the courage to look at me in my face
after what they did to my son
so they're gonna see me at every court
date everyone exactly and until we get
Justice for my son
hello
and so yes and and
if note the choice of words that robots
used
as uh she told Jess Dawson us
they didn't have the courage to look me
in my face
not
dignity to look him in my face because
when you look at the video there was no
dignity there
but they didn't even have the courage to
look at her in her face and that's what
she came to the court room to see today
them booked her and her face eye to eye
how could you do this to my son
yes okay all right we'll take a few
questions what did you think when you
heard the words not guilty well sir
they're going to say that you know
that's a procedure that everyone's going
to say and do I'm gonna leave it up to
this the District Attorney's office and
to get them prosecuted and everything
and then they'll find them not guilt
they'll find them guilty I should say so
them saying they're not guilty that's a
preliminary thing everybody's gonna say
that
um and I was expecting it so it wasn't
nothing new